das war die schönste zeit
[Musik]
weil alles dort begraben
also gebt mir ein o o g php
was kommt da raus nein nicht opposition
schon mal gehört er hat irgendwo im
duden steht das auch bei unglaublich
direkt unter masken affäre
stimmen sehr spaß beiseite
opposition wird uns gut tun also wir
haben uns glaube ich dort regiert wir
machen heute ein bisschen oppositions
training sehr gut ja vielleicht einfach
mal was rein rufen stellen sie sich vor
gerade verkehrsminister anton hofreiter
redet geht zum friseur
vielleicht braucht die cdu und die csu
nicht nur neues grundsatzprogramm soll
mal neue witze das ist nicht bei der
jungen union immer frage wann wird
eigentlich mehr gesoffen beim wahlsieg
oder bei der wahlniederlage
bei uns macht das alles keinen
unterschied
groß ist meine
heute ihr euch auf die opposition ja mal
richtig auf den putz hauen und
forderungen stellen
also das was die csu eigentlich immer
noch genau haben sie nicht angst wenn es
keinen bundesverkehrsminister gibt der
geld nach bayern rüber schaukelt dass es
hier bald so aussieht wie in nrw
werden gemeinsam hinkriegen aber klar
war auch dass der bayerische
staatsminister dafür gesorgt dass das in
bayern was vorangeht und das ist ja auch
gar nicht erst ja ich würde sagen als
bundesverkehrsminister ist seine aufgabe
noch ein bisschen weiter als da konnten
wir viele straßen in bayern gut sind
danke an die an die danke für deine
gelder von berlin nach bayern hat super
gemacht aber jetzt opposition aber nicht
so schlecht muss man nicht auch das
positive an der rolle opposition sehen
weil das gutes im bundestag werden ihre
abgeordneten endlich nicht mehr von den
lobbyisten belästigt also das würde ich
so nicht sehen weil wir wirklich gerne
gestaltet und regieren und lobbyist sind
auch mit den vertretern übrigens
lobbyisten sind auch
gewerkschaftsvertreter lobbyisten sind
auch drei bis fünf user also sie haben
viele lobbyist die lästigen alle
möglichen ich kann bei meiner mutter
schweren ich habe keine
unionsabgeordneten maske angedreht ja
das war
also das war auch definitiv nicht gut
den kubanern deutschen sebastian kurz
gefordert alisa noch ein paar tage
warten das ist gut aber
das ist ja das schöne bald hat er eine
echte sebastian kurz zeit ich glaube ich
auch nicht dass er dann nach deutschland
kommt habe ich nicht den nehmen wir gar
nicht auf
also das ist dann doch noch die harte
linie der
kriminelle asylanten will man hier nicht
haben
kennen sie das wort opposition
aus einer düsteren vergangenheit
kommt jetzt wieder
über hat man es ab ich erkläre es ihn
mal also man muss gegen die politische
führung sticheln und sich für den
besseren halten also für sie ändert sich
eigentlich nicht
[Applaus]
hallo youtube unten könnt ihr den kanal
abonnieren er deutet nach unten in die
info box neben mir gibt es weitere
interessante videos verlinkungen komma
vielen dank
[Musik]